Stanley likes actors that show up
in other lines and don't bump into the
furniture and he doesn't want to hear
anything else he doesn't care about
motivation he cares about it in the way
that it better be right to tell his
story properly on Stanley Kubrick
Productions a call sheet was a
suggestion for what we might do tomorrow
it was certainly by no means what you
were going to accomplish he knows had
the wisdom to know that the best way to
be be creative was to allow something to
evolve in an organic way so that when
you bring the actors onto the set you
know really act it out anything you
bring is good enough for him if it tells
his story properly if it doesn't he'll
say do it better do it more interest it
doesn't say how to do it what to do you
up do it again say it right to
you right in front of everybody no
problem the impression I had about him
was that he was 99 Visual and I didn't
think he knew that much or cared that
much about acting and I was wrong about
that because he did have a great eye for
acting